Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show, I am Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire,
sitting in for David Pakman today.
Well, I've already talked earlier in the show
about Republican strategy for the midterms,
talking about the fact that one of the things
they need to do is make sure that Democrats
aren't able to deliver for the American public.
But there's another thing that they're trying
to do.
Republicans across the country are trying
to create these fake boogeymen.
To basically drum up their base and get them
to be angry about something that doesn't even
exist recently writing for Business Insider,
Manny Fidele put out a phenomenal article
that I want to spend some time talking about
because it's just so great.
Title of it here is Republicans are winning
political battles by arguing against nonexistent
boogeymen.
And one of the first examples he talks about
is a tweet, a recent tweet from Ben Shapiro,
where Shapiro was whining about, you know,
the updated CDC guidelines recently.
The vaccinated people need to wear masks.
And Sapiro Shapiro started going on a rant.
About hell, no, he's not going to wear a mask
inside his own house and his wife's not going
to wear a mask inside their own house and
their kids aren't going to do that.
And Republicans got all drummed up and said,
oh, hell, no, that's not happening.
And then none of them bothered to think for
a second that that's not happening.
That's not an actual thing that the CDC said
was was going to happen.
Didn't even come close to implying that nobody
has ever said when you're in your own home,
you have to wear a mask, but that didn't stop
Shapiro from implying that.
And then, of course, getting all of his little
lemmings to go along with it and to become
outraged by it.
And that is just a tiny, tiny sliver.
Of what Republicans are doing, they're trying
to stralman their way to victory in the midterms
and asphodel points out it's because they
can't run on actual issues.
Now, this is something I have been talking
about for years, and this is the point I love
to make.
The Republican Party has not had a new idea
in 40 years.
The last new idea they had this groundbreaking
new thing they came out with and said, hey,
look, here's a thing we've created was trickle
down economics.
And I'm sure we all know how well that worked
out for everybody, but again, to their credit,
it was a new idea.
Just because it was a horrible idea and economically
devastating idea, it doesn't mean it wasn't
new, but that was the last time that that
party collectively put their heads together
and said, what can we do?
And ever since then, it's been a rehash of
the same dang thing every time they get in
power, trickle down, trickle down, trickle
down.
Hasn't been a Republican president in my lifetime.
That hasn't overseen some kind of recession,
at least one recession.
And a lot of it is tied to the trickle down
economics.
And then, of course, Democratic presidents
have to come and try to clean up the mess,
we've never rebuilt the economy from when
Reagan came out and destroyed unions and enacted
trickle down for eight years.
Yeah, it's been horrendous.
Ever since then, the middle class has all
but disappeared here in the United States.
And even when we do have the recoveries like
what we're in now, we're not creating good
paying jobs.
But look at me here, folks.
I am getting off on a tangent.
That's a story for another day and maybe we'll
talk about it.
I've got some more felons coming next week.
But anyway, here's the thing.
Back to the strawman issue, Shapiro is not
the only one doing it.
We have Republican governors all across the
country.
Passing these massive voter suppression laws
and they're doing it, they say.
To get rid of all the fraud in these elections.
Oh, Democrats want everybody to have a right
to vote, they tell us even illegal immigrants,
we've all heard that talking point not just
from the twenty twenty election.
We've been hearing that talking point from
Republicans for well over a decade or two.
Democrats want to give illegal immigrants
the right to vote no.
Nobody ever suggested that ever, ever.
But they use it and the little Republican
lemmings go out and they repeat those talking
points, you see it on Facebook, you see it
on Twitter, you see it constantly because
there's no critical thinking.
They get told a thing that is a blatant lie
and then they go out and repeat it so others
get outraged by it.
Another great example of legislating where
it's not even necessary.
Transgender athlete bans state of Florida.
Sign one of those.
Oh, no.
If you were born a male, you cannot compete
even if you identify as a female.
Now, you cannot compete in women's sports.
That that wasn't a problem we were having
here in the state of Florida.
In fact, even if it were a thing that were
happening, it still wouldn't even be an actual
problem.
But our governor, in between not letting us
protect our kids from covid, has been working
on all of these horribly, horribly oppressive
laws to address problems that don't actually
exist here in the United States.
There is no epidemic.
Of people who were born men and later identify
as women encroaching on women's sports and
just dominating everybody.
That's not happening enough to even warrant
legislation, especially because this legislation
is clearly biased, because it also says, but
if you're a woman, if you're born a woman
and then you identify as a man later in life,
you can still play.
You can play men's sports.
We're totally cool with that.
So, yeah, weird doesn't address a real actual
problem, but the talking points that led up
to that did get Republicans in a frenzy.
They got everybody thinking, oh my God, we've
got this horrific thing.
All the men are in women's sports.
All women are in men's sports.
Who knows what's what.
I'm scared and confused.
And that's why we end up with this legislation,
because they can't actually talk about the
real issues.
We've seen it with the Tea Party, as many
Fidele also points out in his piece, Tea Party
was basically funded by billionaires from
the start, convincing people that Obamacare
was going to be communism.
Or that you are going to be taxed to hell
and back in order to pay for this, two things,
by the way, that never actually happened.
But.
They got people to think these things were
true and they went out there and did the billionaire's
bidding.
It's the same thing when you see somebody
like Marjorie Taylor Green refer to Democrats
as communists, they're not communists, but
you say it enough.
The lemmings believe it, the lemmings get
mad about that, the lemmings start to yell,
we're not going to have communists in our
dang country.
No, sirree, Bob.
And they do all of this, in fact, the entire
culture war exists.
Because Republicans are so terrible on real
issues, they can't talk about the economy,
as I mentioned, every Republican president
in my lifetime has overseen at least one recession
during their tenure.
They suck at the economy.
Well, they can't really talk about middle
class because their trickle down economics
have destroyed the middle class.
They can't really gripe about wages and what
to do about that, because they're the ones
kind of holding up the whole increasing the
minimum wage thing, they can't talk about
health care because, well, they don't want
anything to change.
And the current system is killing people.
They don't want to do anything that's actually
going to benefit real American citizens.
They only care about their wealthy donors.
You know, repealing environmental standards,
increasing the amount of mercury in the air
and water, that doesn't benefit us, that actually
hurts us folks.
But they still push this as some kind of freedom
from tyranny.
A tyranny that doesn't exist.
Most of these Republican bogeymen don't actually
exist.
But they would rather fight against these
phony enemies because it's really hard, by
the way, to disprove a negative.
So when Republicans go out there and they
just make stuff up to be mad about, like,
oh my God, Joe Biden wants to muzzle all your
dogs out there, how dare he?
We can go out there and we can say, wait,
no, no, he doesn't, but they're going to say,
but yes, he does show me the evidence where
he doesn't.
There's no evidence that he doesn't because
he didn't do the thing.
So you see what I mean?
Like, it is very hard to disprove a negative.
And that's how Republicans win on these issues,
unfortunately, they get people worked up with
lies and misinformation and stupid talk, to
be frank with you.
And then we always end up having to be on
the defensive, trying to correct the record,
and unfortunately that's an uphill battle
because by the time we've finally figured
out a way to address the nonsense, Republicans
have already told 10 more lies before we could
even finish debunking the first one.